tout d'un coup j'ai senti quelque chose
sur mon corps sur mes fesses je ressens
quelque chose et je me suis juste
retourné et j'ai vu qu'il était complètement nu
et il est prêt à entrer et j'étais comme
quoi
j'ai commencé à attraper mes affaires et je
vivais en iran  tu sais que
je ne pouvais pas quitter le stade sans mon
hijab sans mes affaires alors
j'ai commencé à courir il m'attrapait les cheveux
et tu ne peux même pas imaginer avec quelle
douleur j'ai pris toutes mes affaires
[Musique] le
gouvernement a décidé de me fouetter 148  fois
et
je n'ai pas d'autre choix que de vivre dans mon pays
je suis parti en Turquie
pour voir ce qui va se passer et j'ai attendu que
mon ami me dise comme si c'était sûr tu peux
revenir
je n'avais pas de nouvelles tu sais j'ai attendu des
mois et des mois et des mois et je  je n'avais
pas de nouvelles
même en Turquie je ne pouvais donner mon
adresse à personne juste un de mes
amis connaissait mon adresse et
j'avais tout le temps peur comme même mon
meilleur ami qui connaissait mon adresse il
ne savait pas à quel étage je suis
[  Musique]
ici je suis devenu j'ai postulé pour devenir un
zillion
et pour devenir un refuge  e
ils ont dit que vous pouvez travailler, vous pouvez avoir un
emploi et après
trois ou quatre mois, ils ont commencé à
me payer 10 euros par jour,
donc je n'avais pas d'autre choix que de faire confiance aux
gens et j'ai commencé à vivre
avec des inconnus
et je parlais avec ces gars et
je disais pourquoi m'aidez-vous
avez-vous besoin de sexe voulez-vous une relation
si vous les voulez
je ne suis pas là pour ça ils ont pensé d'accord
je plaisante ou je suis juste comme
difficile à avoir mais non j'étais sérieux
alors ils  m'a viré un par un et
je me suis dit
ta peur c'est de dormir dans la rue
mais ça vaut le coup de vivre avec
ce genre de personnes alors j'ai décidé de sauter
dans ma peur
j'ai pris mes bagages et j'ai commencé à vivre
dans la  rue
bienvenue chez moi exactement chez moi
ouais à cause des caméras
je remettais mon dos ici
et j'étais assis sur mes bagages
et comme ça aucune caméra ne pouvait m'avoir
parce que quand tu es ici ils ne peuvent pas
t'avoir
donc je me cachais  ici
mettant ma tête ici et je
pleurais juste et un jour je suis allé dans le métro
pour
s  j'ai dormi et
j'étais trop fatigué pour en choisir un autre
tu sais siège par siège je me suis juste assis à côté
de la porte
j'ai ouvert les yeux et j'ai vu qu'il y avait trop de
monde
et ils avaient raison je ne peux pas m'asseoir là
tu sais mais je ne pouvais vraiment pas '
Je me suis levé j'ai fait de mon mieux je me suis
levé pendant deux secondes mais c'était
impossible et la femme
tout d'un coup elle l'a remise
sur ma tête et elle l'a mise euh sur le
dos et elle a commencé à le pousser elle a dit d'
accord alors je  Je vais le faire si tu ne
veux pas te lever
je me sens si timide
parce qu'elle avait raison
mais j'étais malade et elle ne connaissait pas mon
histoire
tu sais mais c'était si mauvais et les
gens riaient et
me regardaient et  un gars enregistrait une
vidéo
et c'était fou tu sais
alors j'ai juste commencé à crier
je me lève juste j'ai commencé à regarder
ses yeux
et j'ai commencé à crier comme un fou
comme si je ne savais pas que
ça venait de là mais je  juste
commencé à crier et dans la seconde tout le
monde riait est devenu
silencieux tout le métro
[Musique]
je veux juste sa  y vous savez que les réfugiés
ne sont pas dans votre pays pour prendre
vos places les
réfugiés ne sont pas dans votre pays
pour
faire prendre votre argent prendre vos prix
saisir votre chance les réfugiés sont
ici parce qu'ils n'avaient pas le choix parce que
c'est si difficile de venir pour aussi  un
étranger venu dans le pays
tu ne connais pas la langue tu ne connais pas
les lois tu ne sais
rien et les gens te traitent très mal
quand je disais que je suis réfugié les gens
agissaient
si différemment avec moi et s'ils  étaient
si différents et pensaient du mal
de moi en tant que réfugié
wow qu'en est-il des autres
vous